i be seated everyone we're ready to
proceed that last question asked by mr
belenkus was uh after some discussion
with drawn by mr blinkus mr blinkus do
you have any other questions for this
witness just a few
go ahead sir purple
so as far as your
involvement on that day
the only
information you got with respect to who
the shooter was
was from robert goodman correct yes
and
the only information as to
where exactly the gun was
came from robert goodwin also
yes that's correct he knew exactly where
the gun was correct
he said underneath or under him
something to that effect
i have nothing further what redirect
corporal was the gun exactly where
robert goodwin said it was
underneath underneath mr bear so no
further questions all right you may step
down thank you corbin please don't
discuss your testimony with any other
witnesses in the case there is a chance
you may be called back as a witness if
something else arises during the trial
very good thank you sir you're free to
go
mr shellhorn call your next witness
please thank you judge the state we'll
call officer john wardenberg
good afternoon officer please remain
standing place your left hand on the
bible there on the witness stand raise
your right hand please listen to my
court clerk please in the presence of
almighty god that the testimony gives to
this court regarding this matter shall
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth
please state your name as well your last
name for the record john wartenberg w
u r t e amazon mike b-e-r-g thank you
have a seat officer please keep your
voice up nice and loud if you don't
understand a question posed by council
please indicate that okay and if you
hear an objection during the course of
your testimony or a question please
don't answer the question stop you're
testifying until i rule on the objection
all right very good thank you mr
shellhorn your witness thank you robert
officer can you please introduce
yourself to the jury and tell them where
you were
officer john wardenberg washington
township police department of mars
county and approximately how long have
you worked for the washington township
police department 21 years
where are you currently assigned with
the washington township police
department i'm the school resource
officer i work at the long valley middle
school
can you explain for the members of the
jury who don't know what a school
resource officer is what that entails
day to day safety and security mentoring
the students assisting teachers
administrators
overseeing
the drills fire drills active shooter
drills
just a resource just for anybody
including parents as well approximately
how long have you been in the washington
township sro investigation
i'm in my fourth year i believe
drawing your attention back to august
7th 2019
uh were you
in that position at that time
i was it was summertime but i was still
considered a school resource officer
so my follow-up question is what does an
sro do at in washington township during
the summer
summer time it varies more of a utility
i've been in the detective bureau
previously
i've been in patrol by cis traffic so
kind of wherever they need me
through the summer is where that's where
i go for the day
now with respect to august 7 2019 in
particular do you recall if you were
working that day i was and what were you
uh doing that day in the early afternoon
i was actually the role of the school
resource officer
school was supposed to start late august
and i was meeting with superintendent
uh middle school principal and vice
principal
just for the upcoming year safety stuff
security stuff
so i was actually at the middle school
when that call came across the radio now
do you recall how you were dressed that
day
class b uniform
summer which is this uniform minus
that's high in short sleeves
which uh that uniform the class b looks
like it has patches on the both
shoulders as well as a badge yes
now you indicated that uh on that day
you were at the school when there was a
call
can you tell the jury what your
impression of that dispatch call was
i was in a meeting i had my radio on
mars county dispatch sends out what we
call tones so it's an alarm to let us
know it's a big call
um so i heard the tones so i knew to
kind of clear the air and listen
and over the air they informed that
there was an active shooter at 411 west
mill road
based on the nature of that call what
did you do
i immediately left
i
entered my vehicle and headed west
towards 411 i was at 51 west mill so i
was a couple miles
from that location
now the vehicle that you were driving
that day uh can you tell the jury about
that
so because i'm my position was uh kind
of a fill in that day so i had
the very last vehicle that was available
it was kind of stripped down it wasn't
marked
no mvr
no equipment in it
lights and sirens i did have
but it was uh just an extra vehicle as
the primary officers had had the vehicle
so they could do their job
had you ever been to 411 west mill road
before
years ago
15 18 years ago what did you know uh was
that 411 west mill river i knew it was a
horse farm
did it have any sort of a name
uh there was there used to be a sign on
west mill it said hawthorne hill
based on that prior uh
what was the nature of the prior call
where you were there 15 or 20 years
before emergency call squad call i
believe
i i don't know if it was a student or a
camp or or somebody somebody fell off
the horse so it was a medical car
and so based on that uh prior medical
call had you been
onto the property to uh assist with that
call yes what was your
understanding of the general layout of
the property i knew there was a front
house uh you know there was a long
driveway that led to
the barn stable area
now when you uh went there on august 7
2019 were there any other police
officers on scene when you arrived yes
uh corporal hammer
and you recall uh
did you see him his vehicle or something
else i saw his vehicle do you recall
where you saw his vehicle
i made a left as i was traveling west
made a left onto the driveway
and
50 feet maybe 25 feet the guy saw his
vehicle straight ahead of me on the
driveway on the driveway was there
anything that you took note of about the
position or the state of his vehicle
i could see it was unoccupied
it was
just past a smaller driveway that went
off to the left of the major driveway
when you saw that vehicle there what did
you do
i pulled up behind him or behind his
vehicle i got out
uh i cautiously headed to the house
trying to listen i i couldn't see
my my view was obstructed from a large
pickup truck that was to the left
uh so at that point when you got out of
your car uh after seeing
corporal heimer's car did you see
anybody i did not but you indicated that
you went in the direction of the back of
the house yes um did you go
past or around or near that uh pickup
truck i did
at some point did you see people
i did as soon as i rounded the front of
that vehicle
at this point did you have your
uh
your firearm out i did not
now what did you see or can you tell the
jury what you saw when you came around
the pickup truck i saw a corporal heimer
he was kneeling over
um
a body who i there was a lot of blood
everywhere he appeared to be
holding the chest i assume that's where
the wounds were he had a gun out it was
pointing at somebody laying
on their face
[Applause]
i asked him what he needed
uh he informed me he needed medical bag
now let me um break that down did you
know who any of these people were when
you arrived on scene i did not during
the course of the investigation and the
follow-up did you come to find out who
they were i did uh with respect to the
individual that uh corporal heimer was
giving medical treatment to was that a
man or a woman a woman and did you come
to find out who that woman was i did can
you tell the jury who that was that was
lauren counteract
you also indicated that uh corporal
heimer had his gun out and there was
another person there was that a man or a
woman that was a man and did you come to
find out who that man was i did
who was that mr barrister do you see the
individual that you saw uh that you're
identifying as mr barisson here in the
courtroom today i do could you identify
him for the record by an article of
clothing that he's wearing a white shirt
yellow tie
identifying a defendant mr barrisone for
the record
were there any other uh
people in the area at that time
it was an individual off to my right
um
chasing a small dog around
and was that a man or a woman that was a
man did you come during the course of
the investigation to find out who that
man was i did who was that mr griffin
now you indicated that you're first uh
approaching to the scene
corporal heimer told you that he needed
medical equipment yes what did you do
so i informed him that i did not have my
regular vehicle and that i didn't have
any equipment in that vehicle
did you end up getting medical equipment
from somewhere else i did
corporalheimer instructed me that he had
those items in his car so i went to his
patrol vehicle and retrieved what we
call a go bag
what's your goal
it has chest seals tourniquets it's
basically a stop to bleed type bag
did you go get that equipment i did and
what did you do with it i came back to
him and dropped it next to him
and
proceeded to assist him handcuff mr
barrison
do you recall whose handcuffs you use
mine
and you recall where uh the defendant
was handcuffed
to his back
behind you
had you ever met the defendant before no
during the course of uh this going on
did any other officers arrive on scene
yes as we were handcuffing mr barristone
officer hensley arrived on scene
and what did you do after you were done
uh assisting with handcuffing medicine i
turned my attention to mr goodwin
and you recall where he was he was again
still off to the right of us um
kind of like in an open area of the yard
again chasing the dog around
did you see at any point uh did you have
a chance to make observations of the dog
i did what was your impression of the
dolphin
small noisy dog
and uh i guess is it fair to say if you
said mr goodwin was trying to get it was
it
running around it was excited yeah he
was having a hard time grabbing it did
he ultimately get the dog he did and do
you know what happened to the dog i
instructed him to put it inside i knew
that medical personnel and a whole bunch
of other people were going to arrive on
scene so
it was another distraction that i think
we needed did you see uh where the where
mr goodwin took the dog they put it just
inside the door of the back steps
did you lose sight of him at any point i
did not
after mr goodwin put the dog inside
where did he go he came back out and i
went to have a conversation with him
uh what would you describe his demeanor
today
after he was not focusing on the dog any
longer he kind of i think realized what
was going on he got a little excited he
was concerned
stressed
did you do anything with respect to him
i did i handcuffed him for his safety
and everybody else's safety and you
recall approximately where that was in
the area so by the time i handcuffed him
more officers arrived on scene
i did handcuff him
in between a patrol vehicle and i there
was a gravel a pile of gravel
judge at this point i'd like to display
s389 which has already been entered into
evidence
yes go ahead
all right for the record s 389 which
isn't evidence is being displayed on tv
monitors in the courtroom for the jury
officer wardenberg you've seen s389
before yes what is s389 a diagram of
the residence and the area behind it
so i'd just like to go back and discuss
with you uh
where certain things happened that you
described you indicated when you pulled
on to scene you saw
corporal heimer's car
yes
and judge if i could approach yes
this is not perfect
but it's a point there
so i'm going to ask if you could use
that if i ask you where certain things
are judge i'm not entirely positive that
the jurors in the gallery will be able
to see that but i would ask after we do
it the first time if we could do it over
there too
could he go down and do it yeah
would you come down in here officer if
you would just be careful with that
laser pointer don't shine it in anyone's
eyes
next to that screen and point with your
hand on that screen and you can use the
uh points around the other screen
just kind of make sure i want to make
sure these jurors can see you too
so maybe you can stand on this side okay
i'm going to sit down so i'm not in the
way all right thank you is there a
question posed to the officer no judge
i'm going to ask
you if you could point out now that he
has a pointer and he's next to the
screen if you could point out where he
approximately observed officer heimer's
car
looks like you're indicating just uh
almost to the
top left of where that utility box is
on the main driveway yes
where is it
i'm not sure this will work no it looks
like it faded out already
well we gave it a try fine
so
officer if you could uh just go over and
point out to the jury on the screen over
here
corporal heimer's vehicle is
approximately here
thank you and judge it did it appear
that the jurors in the gallery could see
but if you could just ask if it was they
were blocked
yes did any of the jurors have trouble
seeing where the officer indicated yeah
i thought this juror would um would
but can you just go over to that screen
so um that you're
at zero number 12.
and then before i have you sit down
officer ortenberg if you could stay on
that screen and you could just point out
for these jurors in the gallery the
approximate area where you were dealing
with mr goodwin when you indicated that
you
first
place in the handcuffs
and if you could also show on the other
screen so that the jurors in the box can
see
and you're indicating on the driveway
just to the left of the gravel pile as
it's depicted on this diagram yes
all right thank you if you can have a
seat
now you indicated officer that at the
time
that you placed mr goodwin in handcuffs
that there were other uh police
vehicles arriving on scene yes and i
think you indicated that one of those
vehicles had pulled into the driveway
yes and that was
approximately the same area where you
just pointed out you said uh where you
put the handcuffs on the sticker correct
do you know where the firearm was uh or
did you know there was a firearm
involved i did did you know where the
firearm was at this point i did not
at some point did you locate it i did
can you describe for the jury where you
located it so
as i was handcuffing mr goodwin i did
notice it
in that same area
off to the right of the gravel pile
and are you indicating right
based on the diagram or right based on
when you would enter into the driveway
based on that
based on the
diagram so actually
so
at the bottom of the screen at the
bottom of that gravel pile
so if i'm facing the gravel pile it's to
my right
now what did you observe the handgun to
look like it was black with pink on it
can you uh at that point um did you
recover the firearm i did can you tell
the jury a little bit about when you
recovered
uh but you did
i i saw that the chamber was open so i
believed it to be empty but as a
protocol i look into the chamber and
didn't see around in it
the clip was also missing so i knew that
it was safe to handle
and i held it
temporarily trying to figure out a safe
spot to put it as i knew
medical and everybody else that needed
to come to the scene was coming
and i just didn't want a gun laying out
in the middle of the parking lot
officer in front of you there should be
a box that's marked s-177
uh can you open that box
do you recognize what's inside the box i
do what is it that is the gun that i
recovered that day and does it appear to
be in the same or substantially the same
condition as when you recovered it
the slide is open however it did not
have the safety locks on it
now if you could just hold that up and
if you need to stand up so these folks
in the back could see
where you're pointing to but if you just
stand up and hold it up and indicate you
had said something about the slide and
the position of the slide if you could
just point that out for the jury what
you're talking about so this area here
and with this open it indicates to me
that there's not around charged
and in spite of it having the uh the
safety
zip ties and locks and everything right
now
that is the same position the slide was
in when you saw it yes
so you indicated that you picked it up
and you secured it until you could find
a safe place to keep it correct
ultimately where did you put that gun
in the back of a patrol vehicle
and where was that patrol vehicle park
it was parked in front
it was parked up to the gravel pile
facing the gravel pile
do you know who had driven that vehicle
i believe corporal fellini
judge at this point i'd like to uh
move into evidence s-230
and s-231
two photographs i don't believe there's
any objection
any objection mr blinkers to 230 and 231
all right those items will be admitted
into evidence
officer i'm first going to draw your
attention to s-230 that's on the two uh
big screens here
is that a picture of one of our patrol
vehicles
and is that the same patrol vehicle you
were just discussing that was parked in
the driveway facing into where the
gravel power was yes
is there anything uh different about
when this picture was taken that night
and from uh the time when you secured
the gun inside the car the evidence
markers were not there
and you're indicating on the left-hand
side in the background yes then well the
number three as well that was not there
it had not been deemed crime scene yet
now can you tell the jury um
what is in the back of the
patrol car that you put there
the black and pink handgun and is that
on the i guess the floor of the back
there yes
i'm next going to draw your attention to
s 230 231 excuse me
is that the uh
same vehicle excuse me the same handgun
that you placed in the back of the
vehicle yes and that's just a close-up
yes
at the time when you placed the gun
there had you done anything to
manipulate it or change uh
the position of the slide no
was that magazine in the back of the car
when you put the gun in yes
did you see who put that there
no
now you mentioned uh that other officers
arrived
did you see other officers
giving medical attention to lauren
cameron i did
are you aware whether mr goodwin
received any medical attention from the
emts on scene i did not see that
do you know whether or not the defendant
received any medical treatment i did not
see that either
after you assisted
corporal heimer with uh handcuffing the
defendant did you have a chance to make
any observations of what he looked like
um
i saw some blood uh
there was just blood in the area in
front of both parties
if i could just have a moment
just a few final questions for you
officer did you have any other part in
the investigation there at the scene at
the farmhouse
uh i did what was that so shortly after
securing the handgun in the back of the
vehicle
i was asked to help clear the house with
three other officers for
any potential other dangers or injured
parties inside
after doing that
were you given another assignment i was
what was that
i was escorted by morris county
prosecutor's office to go up to the barn
and help
secure it as they informed me of search
warrants
being written
judge i don't think i have any further
questions for officer wardenberg at this
time
all right very well cross-examination mr
malinkas thank you
officer uh
isn't it a fact
that when you arrived on the scene as
the second person
michael barristone was partially
conscious
yes
that's what you put in your report
correct
incoherent is the word i used
partially conscious
and incoherent correct yes
and
when you arrived
hamer was
dealing with both cataract and
my client michael barrasso
yes
robert goodwin was running around the
yard correct
yes um how long was he running around
the yard for
after after you arrived obviously
i'm not sure minutes
minutes
chasing after absorb yes
when you say chasing
where exactly was he chasing the dog
there was a cleared section just past
the gravel pile in between the house
that driveway the gravel driveway stops
then it goes into grass
so
away from us
but it was
kind of off to the
side yard of the house
still behind the house but off to the
side
and
he was having problems getting a hold of
that dog it seemed it i again i wasn't
completely focused on him at the moment
as we had the other tasks at hand but it
seemed that though the dog wasn't
listening to him
now
at some point in time he's told to go
inside the house correct
i told him get the dog out of the area
yes
he basically picks up the doors and he
goes inside the farmhouse they didn't go
completely inside the house he opened
the door and he put the dog in
he never completely crossed the
threshold
he was able to put the dog down
do you recall saying in the report
as mr goodwin ran back out of the
residence mr belinkus
you're reading from his report
yes
shouldn't you show him the report
well you didn't you didn't he didn't ask
him if he recalled it
do you recall mr goodwin
running
back out of the residence
and becoming emotional
i remember coming back down the steps
yes
steps not residents he was partially in
the residence so he partially came out
of the residence
did you search
robert goodwin at any time i did not
so if i approach the witness just show
them a picture or i can put it on the
elmo
is it an evidence
no i'm going to ask them
be recognized yes
they haven't identified the photograph
i'm showing you what has been marked
800
92
and asks you if you recognize
what's depicted on this
i've never seen that photo before
did did you see the dog in the photo
before
not from that angle i don't recognize
the dog like that okay
now while you were there
at any time
no i did not
now
you indicated that
after uh the area was secured
you took part in uh
securing the entire residence correct in
the scene
just the residents not the scene with
three other officers we actually went
into the house okay
and uh um
was the morris county prosecutor's
office at the scene at that point while
he was there
i don't recall there was a lot of people
[Music]
were any assistant prosecutors there
while you were there
eventually i don't know exactly when
everybody arrived
i'm not referring to
when
at any point in time where you were at
the crime scene did the morris county
prosecutor specifically assistant
prosecutors show up at the scene
i don't know yes
thank you no further questions
all right any redirect
no judge all right thank you you may
step down sir please don't discuss the
case with anyone
sir all right very good
all right mr shellhorn call your next
witness
the state we'll call please brian bailey
hi detective please remain standing for
a moment place your left hand on the
bible on the witness stand raise your
right hand and please listen to my court
clerk as she administers an oath do you
throw in the presence of almighty god
that the testimony confidence court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth yes please state your name we'll
spell your last name for the record
detective brian bailey b-a-i-l-e-y
thank you
have a seat please detective please keep
your voice up nice and loud if you don't
understand a question that is posed to
you please don't answer it just indicate
you don't understand the question and
i'll make sure council rephrases it
all right very good thank you
detective can you please introduce
yourself to the jury and tell them where
you currently look
my name is detective brian bailey i
currently work for the somerset county
prosecutor's office and i'm assigned to
the
crime scene investigation and fire
investigation unit
and approximately how long have you
worked for the somerset county
prosecutor's office since august of 2021
where did you work before that
previously with the mars county
sheriff's office and what was your most
current assignment with the morris
county sheriff's office i was assigned
to the crime scene investigation section
did you also work for any other
units or sections with the sheriff's
office the morris county sheriff's
office when you work there prior to me
joining the bureau of law enforcement i
was a
with the bureau of corrections with the
mars county sheriff's office i did two
years at the jail
and i apologize if you said this and i
missed it but approximately how long
were you with the crime scene
investigation section uh approximately
four and a half years
do you have any prior training in uh
crime scene and processing crime scene
yes
do you have any training in ballistics
yes
have you ever taught any courses related
to crime scene processing yes what uh
specifically
i teach uh crime scene photography for
the new jersey state police crime scene
investigation course
all right i want to draw your attention
back to august 7th of 2019 you were
employed by the morris county sheriff's
office at that time yes
and you've mentioned the the crime scene
investigation section several times can
you tell the members of the jury
basically what the rules and
responsibility of that unit we did yes
as a crime scene detective
our basic responsibilities are to
respond to numerous different crime
scenes
throughout morris county
we are tasked with photographing and
documenting the crime scene whether it's
through photographs through a diagram uh
could potentially even be a 3d diagram
um
also with collecting evidence
documenting where the evidence is
collecting it and processing the
evidence how does the morris county
sheriff's office csi unit typically
become involved in an investigation
typically they are called out by uh
either the town where the the crime or
incident could occur or by the
prosecutor's office
now with respect to august 7th 2019 were
you involved in an investigation that
occurred in washington township yes and
did your involvement in that
investigation happen differently than
the process you just described yes can
you tell the members of the jury how you
came involved with that investigation uh
that day i was on my way to work um at
approximately two o'clock
uh while on my way to work i live in a
close neighboring town
an alert came across the radio broadcast
basically stating there was an active
shooter in washington township
i then responded to the scene
got the address through the through the
comm center responded directly to the
scene as a law enforcement officer
when you say you responded as a law
enforcement officer are you a law
enforcement officer when you work in the
crime scene investigation unit yes and
so what was different about the way you
were responding on that day versus when
you would respond as a crime scene
investigating detective uh we weren't
initially called out for a crime scene
but based off the broadcast it's any
responding officer in the nearby area
respond to help
do you recall approximately what time
you heard that on the radio
approximately 2 13 in the afternoon
i think you indicated but but if you
didn't uh are you aware whether that was
at 411 west mill road in washington
township it was at 411 west mill road
washington township and uh do you recall
approximately what time you got to that
scene approximately
2 30 in the afternoon
had you ever been to that location
before no
when you arrived can you tell members of
the jury what you saw first
when i arrived on scene i saw numerous
law enforcement officers um
from the washington township police
department also surrounding towns uh
numerous emergency medical services
and
um when i pulled up to the driveway i
got out i saw mr barristone on the
near the white uh trailer and mr goodwin
by one of the police cars and mrs miss
can can renek
was being uploaded onto a stretcher
did you know who all those people were
before you arrived no and are you
familiar with them based on your
involvement in the investigation based
on my involvement with the investigation
yes now you indicated that you saw an
individual you just said was michael
barason yes do you see that person in
court today yes could you identify that
person for the record by an article of
clothing they're wearing uh a white
shirt i'll stipulate he's identified by
all right very good the witness has
identified the defendant michael
barrasson for the record
continue mr shellhorn thank you judge
now you indicated that he was by a white
trailer yes do you recall what he was
wearing when you arrived
uh i do not recall exactly what he was
wearing but i do know that i don't know
if he was wearing his clothing at the
time but as some of his articles of
clothing were removed by uh emergency
medical services
did you
recover during the course of processing
the crime scene some of those item items
or articles of clothing yes
were medical personnel actively uh
attending to the defendant yes as well
as to mr goodwin yes and i think you
said uh ms canorack as well yes
based on on that by the time you arrived
on the scene how would you describe it
it was very hectic being that the the
circumstances of the the situation um
there was a lot of people in and out of
the scene and yes i responded as a law
enforcement officer but being that i am
crime scene-minded
i did notice our direct scene which was
in that driveway area
and started removing different personnel
from that area that didn't need to be
there if they were tending to mr
barristone mr goodwin
they were removed from that direct area
in a typical response to a crime scene
or potential crime scene
what do you do first when you get there
make sure the scene is secured and why
is that
for the safety of any officer there and
to make sure that our evidence is
preserved and the scene is preserved to
the best of its ability
once a scene is secured
what
would be the role of csi thereafter
photography is big
also sketching like i said before we're
going to document the area and then
start collecting evidence
is it fair to say in this particular
case uh that you're familiar with the
scene based on having processed it yes
judge i'd like to show detective bailey
s 389 which has already been moved into
evidence
389 will be shown on the monitors in the
courtroom
detective bailey the the jury has
already seen this several times this is
s 389 but i do want to ask you some
questions about it
what do you recognize s389 to be a
diagram of uh
411 westmill road is the driveway area
and patio back patio
and are certain things that are shown on
this diagram do they reflect uh items of
evidence or observations that you made
while you were processing the scene yes
now you had indicated previously that
when you first got on scene you saw the
defendant receiving medical treatment in
the area of a weight trailer yes do you
see that area on this uh
diagram yes can you tell the jury where
that is
uh it's towards the front of the the
bottom of the tv
the all the way to the left for next to
the pickup truck
uh on the bottom on the bottom where the
bottom where it says approximate
location of suspect medical treatment oh
yes yes
that's the arrow is that the area you're
talking about yes right there
and you indicated that ms canreck was
also receiving uh medical treatment yes
do you see that area where you observe
that happening on this diagram
yes up by the table where it says
approximate location of victim medical
treatment
after you got on scene and had a chance
to evaluate what
the scene appeared to be did you speak
to anyone
i spoke to numerous members of the
washington township police department
and why do you do that
um to gather some facts
relating to the case and where our
potential direct scene may potentially
be
that afternoon you said that you
responded to 411 west mill road and you
think you arrived there perhaps around 2
30 or by 2 30. yes
um what was the weather like on the
afternoon of august 7 2019.
when i arrived it was
your typical clear summer day and within
a half hour the started getting very
cloudy and start opening up to a
downpour
do you recall approximately how long it
downpoured for
no
but it was around three o'clock in the
afternoon 305 in the afternoon
did other members of the crime scene
investigation unit participate in the
investigation yes and do you recall
approximately how many individuals were
were participating
um
pretty much the entire unit at the time
large was the unit at the time
uh nine detectives i believe
uh
are there different roles assigned or
responsibilities assigned to the
different detectives yes how's that
determined uh basically uh typically
it's with a sergeant when the sergeant
comes out from the particular unit that
day it was a corporal um
he
assigned all the other detectives
basically their job roles for the
investigation what was your assignment
with this particular investigation i was
the lead crime scene detective
so i was tasked with the
photographs and evidence collection for
the case and monitoring the
the entire case
what was your understanding about the
size of the property uh where you were
it was a very large property
now you just mentioned um taking
photographs at a scene can you describe
that process for the members of the jury
uh we start by taking overall
photographs so in this case overall
photographs of our direct scene in the
house
um then we start working our way in to
kind of close it down with mid-range and
close-up photographs and different
potential evidence
and then we start collecting evidence
and you'll see
a close-up of the item in a bag that we
collected
what would be the reason for taking
those what you call overall photos and
then the mid-range photos
it's going to show us reference points
as to where they're collected from
so we're going to kind of work our way
in
using different reference points whether
it's
a house
an evidence marker or another piece of
evidence we're going to use that to kind
of work our way in and reference
different items
now you indicated that it started uh
raining that afternoon around three
o'clock or 305 yes
did you
when did you ultimately begin your
overall processing of the scene in terms
of your full documentation
photography and evidence collection um
when it started raining i saw raindrops
coming i
i realized i needed to load up a camera
so we can accurately depict the scene
and we can document what the actual
scene is
and during my course of photographing
the rain started really coming down
which could have potentially damaged our
scene
so that's when i definitely started
taking photographs
so i marked i also marked evidence as
well so we wouldn't lose it so so with
respect to the the photographs you took
photos uh
when it was starting to rain yes
and
um did that impact the the way that the
scene appeared in the photos from when
you first arrived there
yes
and then you said that you also started
marking some evidence can you explain
that process to the jury so when i
arrived
based off of how hectic the scene was
a lot of people in and out maybe people
didn't realize um where there could
potentially be
crime scene evidence being that i'm
crime scene minded i got evidence
markers and i threw them down actually
over top of the evidence so we could
preserve those so nobody could
potentially um
track evidence or track something into
the scene or out of the scene
um
and then when it started raining what i
did was i covered the cell phones all
the electronic devices with plastic bags
and i used our paint cans which we
collect arson evidence and fire debris
and i kind of dug them around different
shell casings that were on the scene
is there a reason that you didn't just
start processing and collecting the
evidence when you saw it starting to
rain yes we were waiting for a search
warrant but i knew that i had to
document the scene
now i think you indicated this before
but you also
participated in collecting certain
evidence from the scene yes can you
explain what the general process is for
a crime scene detective
uh as you're actually collecting
evidence so as we're collecting evidence
we're obviously wearing uh we're wearing
gloves we are working up with a
mid-range and a close-up photograph and
as we do collect the evidence where
we're logging that on an evidence list
with the date the time the item number
where the evidence is collected from
we're also putting that on to a
evidence bag when we collect it it's
gonna have the case number the date the
time um a description of what the
evidence is and the initials of the
officer that is collecting the evidence
with a photograph
now you indicated that you were the
primary uh
case detective for this investigation at
the scene yes were there other
detectives who were processing other
areas of the property yes
do you recall specifically what areas
you process on the afternoon or evening
of august 7th 2019. yes i've processed
the the direct main area of the scene of
the inside of the house
um and then up at the dressridge the
barn
the clubhouse area
and the office
judge i had given detective bailey a
stack of photos there that i can put
those numbers on the record now i don't
believe there's any objection
from council
all right
give us let's run through the numbers of
the photographs you want the witness to
testify about s203 to s212
s214
hold on a second 206 is already in
evidence
as is 214.
some of these were used with other
officers i just wanted the record to
reflect the additional
rather than listing them one by one
so it's uh s203 to s212 yes
214 to 217
s220 to 222
s224 to 231
s234
s236 and 237
s239
and 240
s242 and 243
s250
s271 and 272
s277 and 278
s31 277 to 278
s287
s301 to s307
s312
s347 to 352
what was that last set of numbers please
347-352
all right mr blinkers have you seen all
of those photographs
yes all right do you have any objection
to those photographs being moved into
evidence
i don't think those were the ones
mentioned
all right so ladies and gentlemen that
set of photographs will be admitted into
evidence by stipulation of the parties
again normally a witness would have to
look at each one and testify that it
fairly accurately represents the the
image or the scene as he saw it and took
the photograph
just to speed things along a little bit
council have graciously
acknowledged that those photographs do
fairly accurately depict the scene as
this witness saw it to be and
photographed it so all of those items
will be moved accepted into evidence
some are already in evidence so 203 204
205 will be admitted
206 is already in evidence
207 208 209 210
to 11 to 12. 214 is already in evidence
2 15 16 17 will be admitted to 20
21 22
24 25 26 27 28
and 20 not 229 230 s230 s231 are already
in evidence
that's 234
236 237
239
240 242 240
or admitted into evidence 250 is already
in evidence
271 272 277
278 are admitted into evidence
287
301 through 307 are admitted into
evidence
and
312 and then
347 through 350.
and 51 and 52.
all of those items uh will be admitted
in the evidence
and be they can be displayed with you as
we move along through the testimony all
right mr shellhorn thank you let's
proceed
thank you
detective billy i'm going to ask you to
describe certain things about the crime
scene now for the jury and we'll use
these uh some of these photos to explain
that
we're looking at s-203 have you seen
that picture before yes and i think this
entire series of photos that we just
talked about you have in front of you in
hard copy
you would agree with me that you took
all those photos yes
and they all fairly and accurately
represent the scene of 411 west mill
road on august 7 2019 at some various
points during your crime scene
processing yes
with respect to s203 what is this a
picture of
oh this is a picture of the residence
and what
angle or vantage point is this picture
taken from with respect to the driveway
or road this is from the driveway um
going up the side of the house
looking to the right of the uh the photo
um what is that uh
is that what is that vehicle on the
right side
that is mr barriston's vehicle the
silver vehicle
now i think this is clear or this should
be obvious but to make it clear for the
record uh what are the dots that are on
the picture
that's rain
so you were taking these series of
photographs at the time it was actively
raining yes
next showing you what's been marked as
s204 do you recognize this picture yes
where is this picture taken on the
property uh behind the residence in the
driveway by the back patio
and
we just looked at a picture that showed
the side of the house
and the pickup truck where would the
pickup truck be in reference to this
photo
can you describe for the jury uh what
the yellow
placard with the number two in it
represents in the center of the picture
that's a piece of evidence that i marked
based off of
the circumstance of the scene so we
wouldn't lose it
it's actually over top of the piece of
evidence
and at the time that you put that
you put that placard down yes at the
time you put that placard down
uh was there already a puddle or
standing water at that point no
what is s205 a picture of
uh it's a more of a mid-range of
the two
placard
meaning that you had identified
potential light a potential of evidence
in that location yes and you marked it
before it started raining yes
next i'm showing you what's been marked
as s 206.
does that generally show the same area
of the the patio in the driveway yes
at the time when you first arrived on
scene
uh is aside from the rain and the
puddles at the time you first arrived on
scene
is this generally how the the scene
appeared
next i'm drawing your attention to s207
what is s207 a picture of
it's another area where there's evidence
with a crime scene marker
and did you put that crime scene marker
there yes
meaning that you identified a potential
piece of evidence in that location yes
when you put that marker down had it
started raining no
what uh
what is on the top right of the uh
corner of the picture
uh like a mulch
like like a mulch uh pile
third pile
drawing your attention to s208 what is
s28 a picture of uh it's the same piece
of evidence with two markers next to it
and what is the reason there are two
markers on this piece of evidence the
basically was one of the markers was
there covering the potential evidence
and then another one was put there so we
know
that there is a piece of evidence here
um
and that we're going to be collecting
that did you know how hard or how much
harder the rain would be that afternoon
no
and i should go back well i'll ask you
this this is s212 is this a picture of
the same area yes
what is the significance of s212
now it's showing the area where if you
see the marker to the bottom left of the
screen there is a fire debris can over
top covering that potential piece of
evidence
and was that the
initial picture that you looked at of
that piece of evidence where it was in
standing water
can you re-ask that
you just indicated there's a can over
the top of uh that piece of evidence yes
with the number two placard on top yes
was that the picture we just looked at a
few minutes ago that was uh in in a
puddle or standing water yes and so what
was the reason for you going back and
and putting that over the top of it kind
of dug the can into the grass a little
bit into the ground being it's a
gravel driveway
kind of grassy area to try and with the
water the amount of water that was
coming through that area to preserve
that so it wouldn't wash away
next i'm showing you what's been marked
as s214
what's s214 a picture of
oh it's the driveway with mr barrison's
truck
and uh what's different about the
time when this picture was taken versus
that set of pictures we just looked at
it's starting to get dark out
by the time that you took this picture
had it stopped raining
uh i believe so yes
what is s215 a picture of
uh it's the same area with the
uh mr barrison's truck and the police
car
and would these pictures be considered
uh
overall photos mid-range photos or
close-up photos overalls
now in the
towards the bottom center of this photo
s215
what's the significance of the yellow
placard that's in the grass there
there's another potential piece of
evidence located there
did you process uh that silver pickup
truck yes
and did you search it yes did you
photograph it yes
this is a s-271
in evidence what is s271 a picture of uh
it's a picture of mr barrison's truck
and is this truck in the same position
that it was when you first arrived on
scene yes
what is s-272 a picture of uh the logo
or the rear passenger door or barristone
dresserage
what is s-281 a picture of it's a
picture of the
in the bed of the truck the
container that was located in the bed of
the truck
and would that be one of those uh cargo
type boxes that can sit in the bed of
the truck and
opens up to store various items yes
you search that yes and this is a
photograph of that yes cargo container
it's an overall photograph of that area
yes
after you took overall photos of the
entire area
did you begin to collect specific items
of evidence yes
how do you determine what the
collector's evidence is
we systematically process the scene and
determine what is directly limited to
the scene that we have
based off the circumstances and the
facts that we gather from other
detectives or in this case patrolmen on
the scene
where did you uh begin collecting the
evidence at the scene that we just
discussed in the driveway
and i'm going to show you a picture s209
what is s209 a picture of uh two cell
phones
do you recall if you took this picture
uh early in the afternoon when it was or
earlier in the afternoon when it was
starting to rain or later in the
afternoon after the rain had stopped uh
it's still definitely raining that
picture
and i think you had indicated that at
least with uh certain evidence that was
in the driveway you marked it with
placards and tried to uh
identify those location of those items
yes
did you do anything with respect to
other items that you saw at that outdoor
scene
that may appear to have been electronic
devices
yes plastic bags were either placed over
top of them or they were placed into a
plastic bag
sure if i may have a moment
certainly
may i approach judge
yes
this is 184 185 175
all right detective bailey you indicated
that s 209 is a picture of two cell
phones correct where were those cell
phones located by you uh the base of the
umbrella on the back patio
and
there's a plastic bag or two plastic
bags next to those phones correct was
that there when you got to the scene or
did you put those there i put those
there for what purpose uh to preserve
evidence
starting with the uh phone on top
uh the black phone
do you see that uh item in front of you
there
and it's marked as s
175
yes
what was and i think you said this
before but what was the reason that you
didn't collect it at the beginning of
your processing and you put the plastic
bags over the top uh we were still
waiting for a search warrant at that
time
at some time later uh that afternoon did
you or that evening did you collect that
item yes and is that s-175 in front of
you
yes
how do you recognize s-175 to be the
phone that you collected from that
location it's in the bag that we
collected it in
and do you do anything to mark the bag
or to identify uh an item of evidence so
that you know that you collected it and
you know where you collected it from yes
the case number the date the time the
item number the description of the item
number and my initials for collecting it
and does that all match with the item
that we're looking at in the picture of
s209 yes
you want to open it
if you could just open it and show it
thank you
now some of these items uh detective uh
after you collect an item of evidence
and you put it into a bag
do you seal that bag yes what's the
purpose of sealing it uh so it's not
tampered with
are some of the items uh that we're
going to look at today items that you've
seen since the day that you've collected
them yes and have some of them been
opened yes did you open some of them for
follow-up processing yes
and are you aware whether
with respect to let's say s 175 a phone
whether that was turned over to another
agency uh for a forensic examination of
the documents or the contents of the
phone yes it was
but is there anything if you look at
that phone that appears to be in a
substantially different condition than
when you collected it on august 7th no
all right drawing your attention back to
the photo of s209
is there a second phone in that photo
yes what type of phone is that oh it's a
white phone i'm i'm not sure the type
off the top of my head and i think you
have s 185 in front of you yes uh is
s185 appear to be the other phone in the
picture yes how can you tell that uh
it's in the package that i put the case
number the date time the item number and
a description of the item and what type
of a phone is that this is a white
iphone
and if you could open that
phone and show that to the jury
detective what exhibit number is that
please uh this is s185 thank you
i'm judge if i neglected to say this
when i showed them to the detective i am
asking for permission to move s-175
s-185
that's 184 insanities any objection mr
blencus
all right those items will be received
into evidence
detective bailey did you collect any
other phones from the area of the scene
uh there in the back of the context yes
and you recall where you collected that
other phone from uh patio table a patio
table that was in the rear of the
resonance
i'm showing you what's been marked into
evidence as s-211 what is s-211
uh it's a a white phone white cell phone
and where is the phone located on the
patio table
and again just to make the record clear
when you arrived on scene with that
plastic bag over the top of that phone
no you put that plastic in there i
didn't why did you put it there
did you ultimately collect that phone
that's uh shown in s211
yes and i'm going to ask you to refer to
s-184
which is an envelope you have in front
of you yes does that appear to be the
same phone that you recovered from the
table
yes
what type of a phone is that
it's a google phone
thank you for showing that to the jury
after you collected those items of uh
those electronic devices at the scene
did you collect any articles of clothing
yes
starting
with the photo s242 what is s242 a
picture of overall
it's a mid-range in the area just before
the steps
of the rear of the residence to enter
the residence
and is the area that we're looking at in
s42 shown in some of those prior photos
that you took of the backyard and the
back of the house it's in the overalls
yes
in particular in this photo s 242 did
you collect any items of evidence that
are depicted in s242 yes a yellow
sweatshirt and a red t-shirt
and those are those are shown in the i
guess the
left-hand side of the picture there the
left-hand side yes
are those items in the same position
that they were uh at least at the time
that you started processing the scene
yes now you indicated that when you got
on scene
uh individuals were receiving medical
treatment yes and who was receiving
medical treatment in this area uh miss
kanernak
and do you recall if those are articles
of clothing that were there at the time
she was receiving medical treatment yes
i'm going to show s182
and 183
to the detective all right
[Music]
you indicated uh that it did rain that
afternoon yes were you able to preserve
or uh put something over the top of
every item at the scene no
with respect to the clothing what was
the state of the clothing at the time
that you collected it
was absolutely saturated with water
and is there any process that you would
typically go through if you were
collecting for example wet clothing
yes we would photograph it collect it
and then once we get it back to the
crime lab it would be placed into the
drying chamber and
dried out
all right i'm going to direct your
attention first to s-182
you have that in front of you yes
and uh what do you recognize s-182 to be
uh it's the bag i collected
red and black sure
does that bag appear to contain the same
red and black shirt that's shown in s242
the photo
because i know i had said i was showing
the detective s182
uh i would like to move those into
evidence
all right any objection
182 and 183 will be accepted into
evidence
so
this is the red shirt
detective you're holding up that red
shirt i see that there's a white piece
of paper there yes can you can you
explain to the jury what the white piece
of paper is the white piece of paper was
used when we were processing the piece
of evidence to determine if there was
any defects
in the clothing and did you do that the
night of the shooting or at a later date
at a later date and after you do that do
you keep that white piece of paper there
in the
uh in with the evidence yes for any
potential trace evidence
now you just held that up
did you do anything during the course of
collecting that uh shirt
uh to change the condition of the shirt
no
and if you could hold it up again judge
if i could ask that that be brought down
to show to the jury members in the
gallery
sure go ahead
and judge just for the record detective
billy just got to the end of the gallery
and he did turn the shirt around to show
the back on the way on his return all
right very good
detective if you could just leave that
there now you indicated that it was
that item for example s 182
was uh soaking wet at the time that you
recovered it yes
and you indicated that it was taken
taken and processed in such a way that
it would dry yes
did you observe anything on that shirt
um
or can you describe the condition of the
ship
uh
it was very very wet that day it was cut
from
uh emergency medical services and there
are defects in the shirt
and when you say defects what does that
mean
when i say defects a
a bullet defect
and i'm going to show you what's been
marked as s349
when you indicated that you had opened
this at a later time and processed it
did you take photos of that
and you indicated that you used a white
piece of paper that's there inside the
evidence bag during that process yeah
what is s349 a picture of uh it is a
picture of two bullet details
and if you could uh
just identify
for the jury where those defects appear
specifically on the
picture there's a bullet defect uh just
below the white collar
um
on like the grayish the dark part of the
shirt and just to the right down a
little ways is another bullet defect
and i know this is a lot of back and
forth but i'm going to ask the judge if
you can come down and just point it out
for the jury yeah just pointed out on
the screen you mean yes yeah go ahead
it's your first bowl of defect right
here
can you come point it out on this other
screen for the jurors who are in the
gallery
first full defect up here by the collar
second order
thank you detective you can sit down
[Music]
when you indicate first bullet defect or
second bullet defect are you able to are
you saying that that is the order that
those defects occurred or are you just
identifying them separately as one and
two identifying them separately as one
and two
now i'm going to draw your attention to
s-348 what is that a picture of those
are two exit bullet defects
and uh again i think
well i guess that's why you put the
white piece of paper into the picture
yes and i think it should be clear but
just in case anyone on the jury is
having a hard time seeing it could i ask
you to come down and point out those two
defects in the picture
you if you could point out on the second
screen
gonna i don't have any further questions
about this particular item of evidence i
can certainly keep going we have other
items to go through but i know we won't
finish with detective bailey today all
right
do you plan on showing him photographs
of the
other item collected
i do as well as having him point those
defects out
well since we're sort of in that general
area why don't we do that and then once
you're finished that will be a logical
point to break excellent go ahead
uh detective billy you could put that
s-182 that shirt back into its bag i'm
going to ask you next about s183
all right detective you have s 183 in
front of you what do you recognize that
to be
a bright yellow sweatshirt the bag that
i collected
and again if i direct your attention to
the screen s243 what's that a picture of
that's a picture of both the red shirt
and the yellow sweatshirt and is that
the
same condition that you located them in
and photographed them in before you
actually collected them as
evidence yes all right i'll ask if you
could open s 183
and detected billy i see uh you just
held up a white piece of paper did you
process this item the same way that you
processed the red and black sweat
t-shirt yes meaning that you uh
removed it from the bag at some point
you took photos of it with that white
piece of paper yes and can you tell the
jury again the purpose of that weight
piece of paper the white piece of paper
is to help distinguish any type of
defect that may be in an article of
clothing or on an item
before i have you show that to the
jury i'm going to to show you what's
been marked as s 350 and evidence what's
that a picture of
that's a picture of the yellow
sweatshirt
and
is this a photo taken at the time that
you were processing it yes in the way
you just described yes
what is uh
this is the front of the sweatshirt
that's the front of the sweatshirt
i'm showing you what's been marked as
s-351 what is that a picture of it's a
picture of the inside of the sweatshirt
far right to the top of the screen is
the front of the sweatshirt with a
bullet defect
then if you come down to the center of
the screen you have an exit defect and
the back of the sweatshirt then to the
left of the screen is another exit
defect
on the back of the sweatshirt
and i i see that there are uh some sort
of
black objects in there what are those
that's just from the potential um
getting getting shots sitting in the
rain sitting in the dirty water um
not ballistic related
i'm sorry the the are they black plastic
markers oh yes black yes black plastic
markers and can you tell the jury did
you put those there what's the
significance of those yes they're there
to help point out where we see defects
and you're holding the uh
the sweatshirt now yes and you just hold
that up it's obviously a little bit
harder to see in these pictures
if i could help the detective hold this
one up
the nature of the uh
detective i'm going to hold this for you
and ask if you can point out for the
jury
where those defects are
mr shellhorn might i suggest you do it
down here maybe all the jurors
can see it
so in the front of the sweatshirt
we have uh
a defect right here an entrance defect
you're only going to see one
um it is my opinion the sweatshirt was
actually open at the time that it was
struck with a bullet
so you see the one right next to the
judge again i object to him
stand when you object mr blancas please
what's the nature of your objection
with regards to
what he believes regarding where this
sweatshirt was and so forth
again i don't think he's qualified to do
that he hasn't been qualified
mr horney's he went through his training
he hasn't been qualified as an expert to
render an opinion no josh so i agree i i
sustained the objection
by ladies and uh ladies and gentlemen
just disregard that last comment from
the detective about what he believed
happened
is it is this a a pullover sweatshirt or
a zip sweatshirt
do you know if the victim was wearing
this open or closed at the time of the
shooting no
you could just go ahead and point out
that bullet defect again for the members
of the jury on the front of the
sweatshirt right by the patch right here
and then
i'll show you
again we're looking at the s 351
is a picture that's up on the screen
can you point out for the jury where the
bullet defects appear on the inside of
the sweatshirt
the inside there's one here
and then
right here
and you're indicating
the two
detects that would
appear on the picture
the first from the left and the second
from the left yes and where would the
defects be in 351
that's on the far left of the picture
the far left
i'm sorry far left of the picture
that side so if i'm holding it up
the left
i'll give that back to you thank you
judge i don't think i have any further
questions about this evidence at this
time all right very good it seems like a
logical
point in time to break members of the
jury so we're going to take our evening
recess now it's a little bit after 4 30.
please don't discuss the case with each
other or anyone else you're going to
hear me say that repeatedly at the end
of the day
and we'll see you back here try to get
to the courthouse around 8 30 or so i
want to start as close to nine as we can
and once i know that all the jurors have
assembled
uh we'll be ready to proceed council
will of course be here by no later than
8 30 hopefully before in case there's
items we have to discuss in the morning
all right thank you members of the jury
we'll see you tomorrow morning enjoy
your evening
[Music]
oh you may step down
no i think you can tone it off
judge i know we discussed in a break
about my office uh
keeping
custody of the uh firearm even though
it's been moved into evidence
do you want me to keep these up yeah
hold on hold on put it on the record i'm
sorry
do you want my office to keep these
other items that we just identified and
moved in the clothing judge
yes
clothing and the gun you can keep
thank you
okay
[Music]
one other thing i noticed when when my
when my staff is administering the
ultimate witness please don't move
around don't talk just let them
administer the oath okay
thank you
your honor yes um
did you want to reach out to another
judge
no
yes i i will do what's the name of the
witness again
i know judge ali okay
i'll reach out to him now
and mr shellhorn
i understand that that laser pointer can
be charged by way of computer i believe
foreign
you